on me dit dans mon oreillette fatale est
encore dans les loges apparemment il
aura un petit souci j'ai ce que nicolas
druillet ce qu'on a une caméra dans les
loges s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on peut
voir où on est fatale fatah bo doï je te
préviens ce soir tu viens pas touche pas
à mon poste
bah c'est pas sympa depuis quand tu fais
la promo touche elle bat depuis que j'ai
pas envie que tu fasses ton gros
dégueulasse avec enora malagré voilà
c'est pas toujours du cul du cul du cul
[Musique]
sans succès
le
et puis j'étais livré
et aussi des maths et les moeurs des
boulets rouges sans successeur
on peut quand même être un
contrecoeur
2 tu me lis ici pas de souci mais je
suis plus ou vision care + tab la plus
grosse qu'un but sauvage me tape lula
ont bougé d'un bébé j'ai pas emmener mon
genou bébé puis bonne bande de bakar
bazooka
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai hâte
toi et moi
[Applaudissements]
j
reste
bigre
soirée pur dj 30 ans et j'ai pas regardé
ma mon contrat trop sympa que d'état
mais j'ai des belles remporté par
jacques shake ton booty pays
j'préfère par les fautes ribéry j'ai
besoin d'une année sabbatique ménard eu
ma naissance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
restent quelques jours